[Música]
[Aplausos]
qué feo no
estamos tan atrapados con la tecnología
que nos olvidamos que hay otros nos
falta empatía
pero qué es empatía
empatía no es solamente saber que hay
otro empatía también es
entender al otro y para eso nos tenemos
que poner en sus zapatos
hoy les vengo a contar cómo podemos
lograr empatía
pero también con tecnología
hace muchos años
unos estudiantes le preguntaron a la
antropóloga la doctora margaret mead
cuáles eran las primeras señales de una
civilización
la doctora mit
se puso a contarles los alumnos pensaban
que se le iba a decir anzuelos unos de
barro una piedra afilada
pero no la doctora me dijo el primer
signo de una civilización es un fémur un
hueso de la pierna rota y cicatrizado
en la naturaleza si se te rompe la
pierna morís
no tiene tiempo a huir del peligro no
tiene tiempo a tomar agua no te da
tiempo a comer y sos carne fresca de los
depredadores
entonces qué pasa
si encontrás
hueso roto y cicatrizado es la evidencia
de que hubo alguien al lado de esta
persona que se cayó la sacó del peligro
le dio de comer y la cuido
esto significa es el primer signo de la
civilización es ayudar a otro ante la
necesidad
la historia que hoy les quiero contar
empieza con lucas
lucas no tenía un fémur roto
en ese momento tenía 8 años
pero tenía la tercera vez que repetía
primer grado claro cuando lo conocemos
el lucas empezamos a entender
lucas es ciego de nacimiento
pero aparte de ser ciego tiene un
problema en los dedos en los cuales no
puede disociar los modos de forma
separada esto le impide leer y escribir
en braille
y en la escuela le exigían que para
pasar de primer grado tenía que saber
leer y escribir
nos juntamos con un diego que es
informático para ver qué podríamos hacer
para ayudar a lucas
yo soy electrónico y empezamos a
trabajar e hicimos un teclado con
texturas grandes que lukas podía
percibir y podía tocar estas teclas y la
computadora le hablaba lo que lukas ir
escribiendo
a esto se lo dimos a lukas en noviembre
del año 2001 lo empezó a utilizar y en
un mes el paso de grado
hoy lucas tiene 28 años
consultas redes sociales de noticias se
comunica con sus amigos
hoy de 28 años sigue usando el mismo
teclado y nos quiso dejar un mensaje
el mensaje dice hola diego a que estamos
probando sistemas como tema te mando un
abrazo gigante
28 años después
luego
empezamos a hacer un caso y otro caso
con diego y nos dimos cuenta para
trabajar puntualmente
este lo que estamos trabajando en las
herramientas para lucas se llama
tecnología asistiva son herramientas
elementos para
la vida diaria para poder hacer las
tareas de la vida diaria de forma
independiente
resulta ser que cuando empezamos a
trabajar nos encontramos que tenemos que
empezar a trabajar con otras disciplinas
porque informática y electrónica nos
quedamos cortos empezamos a trabajar con
kinesiólogos conformado de oro con
terapistas visuales terapistas
ocupacionales diseñadores industriales
mecánicos gente que trabaja materiales
esto implica sí o sí poder trabajar en
forma interdisciplinaria es muy
importante
la tecnología asistiva son elementos que
los vemos todos los días
por ejemplo un bastón blanco para las
personas ciegas una silla de ruedas un
audífono una prótesis a mí mismo de
hecho lo tenemos más cerca lo que
nosotros pensamos estos anteojos si yo
me lo saco se me hace muy difícil la
vida esto también es para mí una
tecnología asistiva
luego tuve la oportunidad de ser
profesor en la universidad nacional de
córdoba en el área de ingeniería en
rehabilitación que básicamente es lo que
hicimos con lucas
allí aprendí que las personas en
situación de discapacidad en el mundo
son un 15% de la población estos son más
de 1000 millones de personas en el mundo
que tienen algún tipo de discapacidad
no sé si a vos te pasa lo mismo
entender que son mil millones de
personas a mí me cuesta dimensionar lo
pensemos en urgente y no hagamos de
cuenta que somos 50 millones de personas
estos son 20 argentinas juntas pero
todas en situación de discapacidad
eso son mil millones de personas
y hay un problema más que en realidad
la gran mayoría de las personas con
discapacidad están en situación de
pobreza
se dice que discapacidad y pobreza van
de la mano porque la discapacidad genera
pobreza y la pobreza genera discapacidad
esto hace que la gran mayoría de las
personas en situación de discapacidad no
pueden acceder a las tecnologías
asistivas para satisfacer sus
necesidades diarias
teniendo en cuenta la situación de lucas
de muchos lucas que hay en el mundo la
situación de que mucha gente no puede
acceder a estas tecnologías asistivas
empecemos a ver cómo hacer para poder
hacer mayor cantidad de situaciones para
que la gente pueda acceder
una de las formas básicas generando
redes
sabiendo quién hace que a mí me
pregunten si yo puedo arreglar una silla
de ruedas yo no la sé arreglar pero
quizá eso sí sea alguien que lo pueda
arreglar de eso se tratan las redes
otra forma es generar y difundir
proyectos de tecnología existía de bajo
costo o gratuitos
y una idea superadora de esto es lo que
se llama el código abierto el open
source
esto significa que uno publica proyectos
que uno hace con todas las
características para que otra persona lo
pueda copiar lo puede replicar e incluso
lo puede mejorar se colocan planos
circuitos pasos para hacerlo todos los
elementos
necesarios para que otra persona lo
pueda copiar
esto se dio inicialmente
en proyectos en todo lo que es la parte
de impresión 3d una persona en el mundo
genera un modelo 3 de otra persona en
cualquier otro lugar del mundo toma este
proyecto 3d y en su caso lo puede llegar
a imprimir incluso como tiene todas las
formas para poder mejorarlo lo toma lo
mejor a lo que le da la forma que quiere
lo adapta y lo puede imprimir también
y esto también se dio en las prótesis
sucede que
hay gente que de forma gratuita
altruista comparte con otros
prótesis porque le hicieron para otra
persona como son de código abierto otras
personas las toman las adaptan para una
persona que la necesita y le imprime y
la dona
ese es el open source
entre la universidad nacional de córdoba
y la universidad de venecia hicimos un
entorno colaborativo teniendo en cuenta
todos estos aspectos
en este entorno colaborativo
se fueron publicando proyectos con estas
características por específicamente de
tecnología asistiva
por ejemplo un sistema de una persona
ciega no nadadores ciegos que le indica
por medio de vibración en el gorro de
que llegar al final de la pileta
otro sistema por ejemplo es un sistema
para personas con discapacidad motriz
fina que pueda hacer desarrollar el
juego del ajedrez
otro ejemplo por ejemplo es un carrito
ortopédico para perros si también
trabajamos con veterinarios
otro ejemplo también es un tablero de
básquet para personas ciegas el tablero
emite diferentes sonidos y los jugadores
pueden identificar dónde está para poder
convertir
sistemas para poder utilizar la
computadora reforma no convencional en
lugar de utilizar el que el teclado o
utilizar el mouse personas con
discapacidad motriz pueden acceder la
computadora de otra forma
juegos adaptados para personas con
discapacidad visual
personas ciegas o personas con
disminución visual
sistemas de comunicación aumentativa
alternativa para personas que no se
pueden comunicar
prótesis y empresas en 3-d
se hicieron muchas cosas
a partir de esto
te invito a hacer un juego de
imaginación
te imaginas que existe un entorno
colaborativo
donde una persona con discapacidad puede
plantear su necesidad y viene otra
persona un maker y hace una tecnología
asistiva para poder darle una respuesta
te imaginas
viene otro maker en otro lugar del mundo
toma ese primer proyecto y lo mejora y
hace una nueva versión y la pública para
que otras personas también se puedan ver
beneficiadas
imagina que las personas con
discapacidad formen un equipo de trabajo
con makers para poder desarrollar un
producto
porque ya estas situaciones las viven
todos los días y ellos son los expertos
entonces las cosas que se pueden generar
ahí son fantásticas
te imaginas
es participar de una comunidad abierta
inclusiva
colaborativa con empática y cooperativa
imagínate cuánto puedes hacer por el
otro